>>> IT'S ALREADY BEEN A REALLY
BAD WEEK FOR THE DEEP STATE.
HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE LATEST
DEVELOPMENTS AND HELP BREAK IT
ALL DOWN, LINDSAY GRAHAM.
YOU KNOW, I HAD YOU ON --
ALTHOUGH WHEN YOU DON'T AVOID
THE SHOW BY TRAVELING ALL OVER
THE WORLD AND YOU MAKE YOURSELF
AVAILABLE.
THIS IS YOUR FIRST JOB, I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU SAY NO.
>> MY BAD.
>> Sean: AGREE.
STEELE'S STUNNING PRE-FISA
CONFESSIONS, THIS NEW REPORT AND
THE CLOSED DOOR TESTIMONY WHERE
WE KNOW BRUCE ORR UNDER OATH
SAID, I TOLD EVERYBODY IN AUGUST
OF 2016, IT'S AN UNVERIFIED
DOCUMENT -- THE DOSSIER -- AND
STEELE HATES TRUMP AND HILLARY
PAID FOR IT.
YOU KNOW, AS I DO, THAT IT'S
UNVERIFIED, BUT DOES IT NOT SAY
AT THE TOP OF A FISA WARRANT,
VERIFIED?
>> WELL, IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE.
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO SAY UNDER
OATH TO THE COURT THAT THE
DOCUMENT I'M PRESENTING TO YOU
IS ACCURATE.
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT OF
GETTING A WARRANT.
YOU GOT TO HAVE RELIABLE
INFORMATION.
BUT WHY IS THIS SO IMPORTANT?
WE KNOW IN AUGUST OF 2016, ORR
TELLS THE FBI SENIOR LEADERSHIP,
YOU GOT TO WATCH THIS STEELE
GUY, HE'S OUT TO GET TRUMP.
NOW WHAT DO WE KNOW?
THAT CHRISTOPHER STEELE WENT TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE ON
OCTOBER THE 11th TO TRY TO GET
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE TO
RELEASE THE DOSSIER TO THE
PUBLIC FOR POLITICAL REASONS.
THEY TELL THE FBI, THIS IS TEN
DAYS BEFORE THEY GET THE FIRST
WARRANT APPLICATION VERIFIED.
SO TEN DAYS BEFORE THEY APPLIED
FOR THE FISA WARRANT, THEY WERE
TOLD IN AUGUST THAT STEELE'S OUT
TO GET TRUMP.
IN OCTOBER, STEELE GOES TO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT TRYING TO GET
THEM TO RELEASE IT TO THE PUBLIC
FOR A POLITICAL REASON.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, YOU CAN'T
EVEN MAKE THIS UP.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: I UNDERSTAND THERE IS A
FLORIDA CASE AND WE MIGHT GET
INFORMATION FROM STEELE, BUT WE
DO KNOW IN THE INTERROGATORY
WHERE HE WAS UNDER THE THREAT OF
PERJURY, HE ACTUALLY SAID I HAVE
NO IDEA IF ANY OF THIS IS TRUE,
50/50 AT BEST.
DOESN'T THAT THEN RENDER THE
DOSSIER, THE DIRTY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER UNVERIFIABLE?
>> WE SHOULD ALL BE CONCERNED IF
OUR GOVERNMENT IS GETTING A
WARRANT AGAINST AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN WITHOUT ACCURATE
INFORMATION.
WHAT DO WE KNOW?
WITHOUT THE DOSSIER, THE WARRANT
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ISSUED.
WE KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR OF THE
DOSSIER WAS ON THE PAYROLL OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HE WAS NOT A RELIABLE INFORMANT
FOR THE FBI.
HE WAS TRYING TO DESTROY TRUMP
BECAUSE HE WAS PAID BY THE
DEMOCRATS TO TAKE TRUMP DOWN.
THEY SHOULD HAVE KNOWN ALL OF
THIS BEFORE THEY APPLIED FOR THE
WARRANT.
HERE'S WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO GO TO THE FISA
COURT AND TELL THEM THAT THE FBI
HAD PLENTY OF NOTICE THAT THIS
GUY WAS ON THE PAYROLL OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND HE WAS OUT
TO GET --
>> Sean: SENATOR, I'M NOT THAT
SMART.
WOULD THAT BE A CONSPIRACY TO
COMMIT FRAUD ON A FISA COURT?
WHERE I GREW UP IN NEW YORK, I
KNOW DOWN IN SOUTH CAROLINA
WHERE YOU GREW UP, YOU WERE
LIVING IN A BAR, I WAS WORKING
IN A BAR UNTIL 4:30.
WE HAVE SIMILAR BACKGROUNDS.
WHERE I GREW UP, YOU SAY YES,
SIR, NO, SIR, YES, SIR, YOUR
HONOR, NO YOUR HONOR, AND IF YOU
LIE TO THE JUDGE, IT'S NOT GOING
TO WORK OUT WELL IN THE END.
>> HOW COULD YOU NOT KNOW STEELE
SHOULD BE LOOKED AT REALLY HARD
GIVEN WHAT ORR SAID AND GIVEN
HIS ACTIONS ON OCTOBER 11th?
YOU GOT TO REMEMBER, STEELE WENT
TO THE STATE DEPARTMENT -- I
DON'T KNOW WHY HE WENT TO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT -- FOR THE
EXPRESS PURPOSE OF HAVING THE
DOSSIER RELEASED BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
>> Sean: WE HAVE MORE E-MAILS
COMING.
>> BEFORE THE WARRANT.
>> Sean: BEFORE THE WARRANT.
JUST LIKE ORR SAID.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: LET ME GO TO ROBERT
MUELLER FOR A SECOND.
YOU SAID YOU DON'T CARE WHETHER
OR NOT HE TESTIFIES, THAT'S UP
TO HIM.
TRUMP MAY STOP IT.
I DON'T KNOW IF I WANT THAT.
I WANT TO KNOW WHEN DID HE KNOW
THERE WAS NO CONSPIRACY WITH THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIA AS IT
RELATES TO COLLUSION OF ANY
KIND.
WHEN DID HE KNOW THAT.
WHY DID HE HIRE ONLY DEMOCRATS
AND EVEN HILLARY'S ATTORNEY AND
ONE ATTORNEY KNOWN FOR
WITHHOLDING EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE
AND HAVING A REALLY BAD TRACK
RECORD AND FAILING, AND WHY WAS
HE NOT CONCERNED ABOUT HILLARY'S
DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER WHEN HE
HAD PLENTY OF TIME TO LOOK INTO
MA DA
MEDALLIONS AND LAWS AND TAXES, I
WOULD THINK THE RUSSIAN DOSSIER
WOULD HAVE BEEN IMPORTANT TO
ROBERT MUELLER.
WHAT DO I KNOW?
>> HERE'S THE QUESTION, WHY
WOULD THE FBI CLASSIFY THIS
EXCHANGE BETWEEN STEELE AND THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI
APRIL OF THIS YEAR.
>> Sean: UH-HUH.
WOW.
NOW, THIS IS PRETTY INTERESTING.
>> THEY CLASSIFIED --
>> Sean: WILL YOU PLEDGE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TONIGHT,
SENATOR?
AS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TOLD
YOU, I THOUGHT YOU HAD THE BEST
LINE OF QUESTIONING LAST WEEK,
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT IF HILLARY'S
INVESTIGATION INTO CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY WAS RIGGED, WHETHER OR
NOT THEY TRIED TO RIG A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, WHETHER A
FRAUD WAS COMMITTED AGAINST THE
FISA COURT, WHETHER THERE WAS
LEAKING OF INTEL, WHETHER THE
INTEL COMMUNITY WAS WEAPONIZED
AGAINST THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
WHETHER OR NOT THEY TRIED TO GET
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES WITH OPPOSITION PARTY
CANDIDATE LIES TO UNSEAT A DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT, ARE ALL THOSE
ISSUES ON THE TABLE?
>> YOU BETTER BELIEVE IT.
WE GOT TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
IT AND MAKE SURE IT NEVER